If you want to vote for Jorge Álvarez Maynes,
here's what you should know.
Jorge Álvarez Maynes is a Mexican and leader of
the orange bench in the rejection of the union.
Born July 8,
1985 in Zacatecas,
Zacatecas He studied international relations at the
Institute of Technology and Higher Studies of the West.
He has a master's degree in public administration,
another in international studies and one
more in constitutional law and human rights.
He has been in the political parties PRD,
new alliance and PRI,
Currently militates in citizen movement,
party to which he belongs since 2 013,
Initiated his career as alderman of the
city council of Zacatecas from 2 004 to 2 007,
In 2 010 he was local deputy of the Congress of Zacatecas,
from 2 015 to 2 018,
He was Federal deputy of citizen movement by proportional representation,
period in which he served as secretary of the commission of culture and
cinematography and the public education and educational services commission.
In 2018 he was appointed secretary general of agreements of the orange party,
In 2021 he was again nominated by citizens' movement as a Federal deputy,
a position he currently holds,
being coordinator of the orange bench and secretary of
the commission of social economy and promotion of
cooperativism and of the commission of metropolitan areas.
According to his blog,
he was the founder of the day in Aguascalientes.19/11/2023
joined the presidential campaign of the governor of Nuevo León,
Samuel García.
Write me in the comments what you think of
the orange pre-candidate and that is why.